you know this experiments my favorite
experiment in it's the best experiment
it's the most reproducible experiment
that you could ever do
and it's to take a glowing splint and
pop it into an oxygen-rich atmosphere
because what happens is the oxygen gets
to the warm hot wood or the carbon and
starts the combustion reaction again
yes so the synthesis experiment really
surprises you you you see the flame but
you also see all of the combustion
products you see water vapor see very
small particles of carbon now I have no
idea what size they are but they're
small and you can see them in the flame
and they're really glowing really hot
excited